Mom what you talking about?
I always have time for you.
Hang on I'll call you back.
I've got something even hotter
and jucier than last time.
Don't move I'll be right there.
OK. What do you have for me?
Mmmmm
Mmm what is that code for
something?
The moon landing was faked
Illuminati the millennial vote.
Mercury is in retrograde meteors
upcoming midterm elections.
M what? Do you have something
for me or not? Sorry here you
go.
My neighbors are suing me
for always
parking on the bocci court?
What's bocci? Thats your big
scoop? Hey.
You want a bite  of my quarter
pounder?
No I've got leads to change.
It's hotter and juicier.
McDonald's knew hotter and
juicier 100 percent fresh beef.
Quarter Pounder burger so good
they'll leave you speechless.